i would fight her even for charity
i would be i would beat you up for her
right now goes hey can you beat up dude
i'm so sorry i have to do this
lauren asked me to do this too oh robin
hood over here
you're gonna step in and beat up a woman
yeah you
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
dude that guy the guy with the
in the tesla whose wife wanted to [ __ ]
the
big black guy huh no the valet guy that
keeps
pooping in there in the bathroom oh
which i'm a homeboy out front there
yeah quit feeding that guy who is that
guy blowing the bathroom up
any chance he gets dude there's a
million cars we'll park
he's charged nobody that guy's in there
he's the worst of all time
bro i've never paid i mean roll right
through i don't say anything to him he
never asked me anything
you we get charged for you every single
time i pay for it he's he see
he oh he sees it yeah yeah he just knows
he's actually more perceptive that he's
slow but he
sees the cars that are there really yeah
he's probably just trying to
get he's got those fiber optics dude
heavy on the fiber
super fiber that dude every now and then
i'll go throw ten dollars under the
bathroom stall bro he is
literally in there every time quit
feeding that guy
when i met that guy he was probably
six three the guy's five one now and
he's 30 pounds heavier
since we've been here he's gotten
heavier no he's not but he's gotten a
lighter i don't think so that dude is
purging himself in there blows that
bathroom
oh he's gonna be a newborn baby he'll he
will be a newborn baby by the time he
gets done
toilet man oh my god it's just
unbelievable man
i wish i could meet his family or
something just look at him like what are
you guys
let's get him in the culture corner him
and his family don't you think yeah
i wouldn't mind having him in the
culture corner what's his name mr ron i
have no idea
don't know his name nick's giving the
guy four thousand dollars has no idea
what his name is
unbelievable business practices hey do
they believe they charge you for parking
nick
uh no we get two passes a month oh good
that people don't get charged
what is this the senate man just the
[ __ ] the checks and balances systems
over here
[ __ ] show unbelievable dude just a [ __ ]
just giving money out to anybody in a
restroom these days
we got the boys from tiny tacos on today
yes sir
are the top so i'm confused are the are
they tiny tacos is that the thing
one of the guy's name is tiny bro quit
licking your
lips dog when you look over at me dog
you can't be wearing that pug shirt man
not expect a little
little love everybody loves a pug yeah i
know that dude
but look then look at the shirt don't
look at me i can't help it man you look
at me like i'm a menu though i look at
you like your
[ __ ] pizza roll doggy
chill out bro dude pattern
get up do your lips like that bro your
lips are all wet you get gloss on this
yeah quit looking at me bruh
why you being crazy man y'all been
smoking the scott day up in here man no
dog you're just different now that's how
we do it now lady dog
what do they look at other man like that
in l.a in nashville it is
right y'all changed man you're all
different in nashville you got the
chains out doggy i got that chain boy
where's the second one from goals i took
the other one off today man i don't want
to go full 400.
you don't want to go full on them not
trying to stunt yeah i feel you
take it easy sometimes you don't want to
see people and make them feel bad about
the change you have
on you know but if they know yours is
fake it probably makes them feel
this ain't fake baby 300 ah that thing
ain't
there's probably plated gold daddy oh
like don't take a shower with that you
know that
oh yeah i don't go right down the drain
yeah you know that
hey it's gonna follow up in the water b
that gold's gonna come
right off dude you could you could you
could put this under a sleeping miner's
nose and he wouldn't even wake up i bet
that thing's not gonna sound off the
metal detector
i don't know man this thing might be it
might have more gold inside of it it's
pretty thick
no i don't think so man
your [ __ ] looks too pricey bro wrong
with that [ __ ] around your neck bro
yeah i know a couple brothers that take
that from me go to dc go to memphis with
that [ __ ] on bro
go to memphis ain't gonna do [ __ ]
have you seen the first 48 which now is
basically the first 4 800 there's been
like 2 thousand episodes
they never solve [ __ ] in 48. oh
pookie yeah pookie uh two months later
pookie showed up at the police
department yeah one one they solved
a year later man yeah
skittles had no idea why he shot up the
child's birthday party
yeah yeah it's always memphis it's
always uh toledo
miami miami every now and then miami
wants a dog
yeah no plenty of winter so there's no
it's like yeah there's no reason for any
of the shootings no
it's just not even yeah at least memphis
it's like it's at a kid's birthday party
or it's at
a quinceanera or something or like a
black quinceanera yeah it's a friend's
wife or some [ __ ] who does the murder
yeah
that's just stunts yeah stunts hasn't
been able to be located by authorities
yeah they're giving an update yeah
biscuits showed up a month later with no
shirt on yeah
everyone gets life in prison yeah that's
how that show ends spoiler
every single first 48 people get life
dude and how much money are white people
making off of black people shooting each
other on that show
go look at the executive producers of
that show dude oh they're bawling dude
yeah think of the guys who came up with
cops yeah
these cops are not doing anything
different they might they might not beat
us many people because on camera
they're but they're not doing anything
differently and then bad boys bad boys
what you're gonna do what you're gonna
do when they come for you
my mom used to put on hand cream and
turn that on hell yeah it was the first
show we were allowed to watch as a
family
oh that's a big deal what you gonna do
again that was the job
and then the dog would get the guy under
the boat oh i love it yeah
they got rid of cops thanks far left
yeah
shot down to cops for the lead first 48
yeah man it'll come back man you think
there's 435 episodes of the first 48.
and i've seen about
434 of them oh yeah tiny tacos is here
huh yeah you want to bring them in
yeah let's get them in man man these
guys are adults huh
yeah yeah am i gonna be having kids
[ __ ] cooking tacos what do you mean
bro i mean are they
tall and stuff dude hit your lips with
some paper what's up playing boys
what's up what's up what's up man dang
bro good to see you guys
man i saw you fellas doing some work in
the in the van over there
popping open the truck doing something
oh y'all out there doing trunk work huh
yeah that's what's up
so now sitting sideways with tacos in
the minivan you know
are you guys uh how'd y'all get into the
taco business man he pulled that closer
to you brother oh for sure yeah and you
can move these or whatever
to eat dog yes you do yeah so
you know which one is tiny this one's
hell yes damn and why what happened to
you uh
i actually used to work in the kitchen
and that's where i got my name uh you
usually get your nicknames in the
kitchen you do something stupid or
something sticks you know yeah and uh i
thought it was gonna be cooler
but turns out when i started i was a
buster you know starting the front of
the house
wanted to make my way to the back of the
house and you know there was this lady
that fits you your clothes and stuff you
know
where is it where at uh tara now i don't
know if you at a restaurant
yeah at a restaurant in a resort in pv
oh damn
so they got this fitting lady you know
it's some mexican lady just
fitting you up touching you you know
what i'm saying yeah and she looks at me
and she goes she already assumes my size
oh
that's like the big biggest mistake for
me yeah because you know because a lot
of mexicans are big on the inside yeah
yeah you know my hands are small my legs
are small but it's all in the belly you
know yeah so she was like try this shirt
on and uh
it didn't fit the buttons were about to
pop out and uh
the homie was like oh that shirt is tiny
on you you're tiny
so i didn't do nothing cool or nothing
it was just pretty cool though my shirt
didn't fit
you know dope nickname though yeah cool
story bro yeah yeah yeah
tiny is a good nickname i think um i'm
trying to think of another good nickname
raphael
that's my first name yeah we get to know
you more than we give you a nickname but
tiny kind of words
yeah it's a big dude yeah it's a oh it's
like a um
reverse psychology counterproductive
yeah and then you guys do the work out
of that van why not get a [ __ ] food
truck no
that wasn't the initial plan we actually
wanted to uh make taco videos okay so
when i approached him with the plan we
were like hey man
you're making these dope videos at your
house i was on manchester united cook
he was a man really yeah yeah baby yeah
baby congrats man girl he's three he's a
boy
congratulations
and is he are you guys full-blooded
mexican yes i am yeah
i'm from mexico you are yeah yeah yeah
yeah what what part
all right yeah we only bought that zoo
we almost
then we had to do some dark [ __ ] so we
got out of it zoos up hose down well
they had a shooting not a shooting yeah
it was like a
murderer zebras yeah and then yeah the
thing burned down yeah and zebras died
you know the cause of the fire uh
i i there's there's not a lot of like
solid police
who didn't get the best reporting back
yeah yeah they just asked for cash
you know if a friend of mine just got
married my friend kevin
oh congrats kevin well he got engaged he
like
he had to do it and where did he use
ring from uh
i paid way too much huh no blue nile he
used blue now
wow man he hit me up and he said what
was the code you guys talk about on cass
and now he's engaged man he's in love
wow so you see what blue now can do for
you yeah
whatever it is your girl's b day your
man's b
this is for marriages whatever doug you
want to get your
your little side piece of gift we don't
limit you i don't
i don't either but what you can do is
save money on some of the best diamonds
out there we're talking about blue nile
the original online jeweler
since 1999. all right praise god man
they have expert advice 24 7 they can
help you pick out
quality diamonds make your
moments sparkle with jewelry from
bluenile.com and king and the sting
listeners
get 50 off of five hundred dollars that
means you spend 500
you get that 50 off this podcast
exclusive offer
includes engagement jewelry you want to
get something quality
they it's cheaper because the middleman
is going the brook and mortar stores
yeah that's code k-a-t-s plus every
order is insured ships free
and arrives in discreet little package
so it doesn't give away what's inside
man
go to bluenile.com today shop stress
free and find your
forever place be in love or hit you know
tell somebody how you feel get them that
rock
go to bluenile.com today
ufc 259 king it
it's this weekend kids and it's stacked
three belts up for grabs that's right
three championship fights and you wanna
make bank
so you can do that by going to
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the uf
of c is putting you in the center of the
action with special odds boosts
for all the kingston listeners once
again i'm teaming up with draftkings to
create a custom parlay
for the big fights they go hey shob what
are you thinking i said this
is my three fighter parlay
and if you bet on this it's gonna boost
your odds three times so
if you bet on these three fighters if
you bet a hundred dollars you're gonna
win 300 that's right plus 300 but all
three have to win
which three i'm glad you asked kids al
jermain sterling
izzy out of sonia and amanda nunes if
they all win their fights and you bet on
the three fighter parlay
boom you bet a dollar you win three
dollars you bet
a hundred dollars you win three hundred
dollars you bet a grand you win
three grand we're going sizzler dog with
my freaking parlay
all right so it's for uh
new and existing customers who take the
brenden shop parlay head to the app now
find the brendan
shop special under the odds boost tab
bet on it and ride along
with your thick friend new users
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app now use the promo code
kats when you sign up bet on my parlay
fighters to win saturday night at ufc
259
take advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code kats if my parlay hits
you'll triple your money
only at draftking sportsbook must be 21
and older new jersey indiana michigan
and virginia only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler
indiana 1-809 with it or in virginia
call 888-532-3500
how crazy i feel like we mexicans
run this country dog why is there not
more of like a mexican so
like i feel like there should be a day
where everybody goes outside and just
applauds mexican americans cinco de mayo
yeah but i don't think that's it really
bro it's not even the real independence
day
you guys don't have a month no i mean
just one gun
y'all deserve something
where everybody comes he fights he
fights this weekend hmm oh he doesn't
fight this weekend oh hell yeah is he
he's mexican oh yeah from guadalajara
wow that's where my mom's from that's
where my girl is from
yeah yeah that's why i heard that your
girl was from all over kalahara and i
was like
flaming heart hot cheeto capital is it
really yes
they love them damn yeah i heard they
snort them up there just yeah oh yeah
you guys need to make a guadalajara
flaming hot cheeto taco son yeah
brother yeah
when you're when you say
warriors we do we should do a sock check
phone oh socks yeah yeah yeah
you guys hire your socks yeah do you
guys have a long shot
you guys just have black socks on though
yeah i did brick flares yeah
why don't they make a sleeping bag for
mexican kids like it's just a big sock
one big sock yeah you fit two i think
everyone has decent socks on but you
know they're going to share right yours
is going to be they're going to try to
fit two kids outfit
yeah i feel like you know i feel like
they should have a mexican or like
appreciation month or something don't
you guys feel like that or you guys
don't even care
i don't know dude to be honest i don't
really you guys like fly under the radar
yeah
yeah i just behind the scenes people you
know i mean
we don't really want the i feel you want
it you know what they don't they also
back off
i just sometimes like uh while other
while everybody else is fighting and
arguing about stuff and
different races are already distance
working just getting the [ __ ]
job done it's just like yeah it's like
just show up do
work keep going so you guys have a brick
and mortar store
no man the the original plan was to make
these tacos right so it's one taco a
week
you film something you know presented or
whatever and at the end of the month
the people get to vote which taco they
want to try so at the end of the month
we do a pop-up shop somewhere
we set up somewhere and whichever taco
is the most you know popular that's what
you're saying that's what we're gonna
serve and that's just one taco just one
taco one taco only okay
and just set up and once we sell out we
sell out for the next month we just
keep turning over tacos pretty much yeah
and it's a specialty taco
yeah so sometimes we'll have a guest and
then like you guys we get we made you
guys specific tacos yeah
with your background and whatever we
have them right here i don't know if you
guys are ready to
this boy been ever since i've walked in
here this dude been asking me about
tacos man and he keeps
looking at my lips wetting his lips with
his tongue bro quit doing that sorry bro
that's how my lips got chapped
really think about food you know just
like so
did you did you guys think of ever doing
a food truck
yeah it's it's in the plans for sure 100
would be a lot easier would it it would
be easier yeah it would be a lot easier
what's the tough parts about getting to
that food truck level like what is it is
it worth it to go from like what you're
doing now
to to a food truck is there more like
possibility for to make money is there
is it more of of a burden like what
would be right yeah well there's
definitely a large market for it and i
think the
hardest obstacle for us is we have
full-time jobs
are you not full-time taco makers yeah
no we're starting we're getting there
what's the regular gigs so i am a yacht
manager
and i work for post office yeah you dude
i [ __ ] love the post office dude yeah
i wanted to uh i see you guys uh the
battle between all the postals and the
fedex i was like they don't want to play
you know what i'm saying
yes yes right usps you don't play with
us you know bro
who's most likely you think to carry a
pistola you think out of the different
people
ups uh dhl probably yeah
you know some shady's going down bro
they're they just wear eyes bro are they
all right they already got that game
[Laughter]
yeah dude and the guy he had the [ __ ]
package taped around his waist i'm like
yeah just go up into apartment building
so you can make it easier for them
you're a yacht manager you said yeah
yeah i work for a company that manages
yachts
so basically yeah no no not really so
dude how crazy is people on yachts
people that have yachts it's crazy
yeah they're balling but you never see
them no that's just like a status for
them you know
right yeah they hardly are supposed to
be one of the worst investments you can
make
as a boat i'm sure but for the staffs a
lot of time the staff are just sitting
there on the boat every day they just
clean it
and tighten it up and then it's just
kind of chill like um
i just got to go on somebody's yacht
long ago and it just blew my mind it was
like
the yacht is kind of sailing around the
con the world or whatever the countries
and then then sometimes the owner will
come and hang out on it
yeah because no one's on that [ __ ] for
like a while no
it's on there right yeah and saltwater
is basically just
acid so it just corrodes everything on
the boat so it needs constant
maintenance and
you you need a crew to manage a yacht
yeah you need that fresh water yacht
yeah a little lake yeah a lake yacht
i heard i heard a story one time that
albert haynesworth bought a big yacht
and put it like in a lake and then it
it didn't work out yeah it lost a lot of
money on it yeah but that could also be
just something that somebody said
so but is the goal to retire from the
regular nine to five gigs
slang tacos all day 100 don't you think
you could get that with a food truck
yeah you pull up hollywood you pull up
to you know venice
abbott kenny food truck days right right
crush it man 100 i've had some
[ __ ] food trucks yeah well i i think i
i kind of see it now as almost like uh
easy money tacos or easy money maybe
maybe easy money food something quick
and you know it's just
you're talking about the trucks that are
out there some food trucks that are out
there right now yeah like
it's like it's just like um but you but
you guys could you
at that this level the level of your
tacos can you knock out a bunch of those
100 percent it's all about the [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's all about the press
now are you ready to see because you
seem like you're ready to freaking mail
in the other job and go
and taco up bro this guy wants a man you
seem like he might be you
kind of thing oh yeah yeah it's gnarly
tacos is
no though oh yeah yeah they don't play
tacos 24
yeah yeah that's you well
nobody else is looking at not googling
tacos
he is they got a show about it man his
name's tiny for god's word
it's a way of life um yeah i'm just
wondering how much how many do how much
do
does it cost to get a truck you think
like how much is that whole thing if
y'all looked into that
business partner the base is like 30 i
think for like something basic you know
just like a basic truck
but i mean we got ideas for it to
customize it just to make it popular
think about this your tacos are
marketing
say less say dude i'm down say
let's say less say more actually yeah
let's look at one right here see what we
got here you see something good here
nick
this one like if you don't even want one
that drives you just want to
take it with this oh you want to really
you're talking about that trailer now
you have a truck uh i got a raft ford i
just need to install nope
especially like a widespread panic
concern no
dude i'll eat a grilled cheese out of
[ __ ] some water
some man laying in a van with a wolf
dude i would easily
uh at a at a widespread panic concert
somebody would have a full rack of ribs
out that rav4
but you guys can't uh get a trail and
hook it around for so we're gonna need
an actual
operating food truck no absolutely
that'd be way easier
you know we just post up tonight nine
tiny's tacos
here's taco of the day you got theo
shirt
[Laughter]
i don't know if i want to all right i
want to help
you we're just spitballing ideas here
yeah yeah
or ping pong yeah ping pong and ideas
back and forth
right and they're not interesting have
you all ever done a um dessert taco
that's for us i mean maybe you're real
taco guys here man yeah my bad man the
gimmicks you know
you gotta i gotta try i try to steer
away from the gimmick stuff really
because you're a drone
i try it kind of it doesn't get me angry
just like oh
bryant people try to kobe bryant taco
after he died you know it was like a
dark meat kind of i'm going to stay away
from this
yeah are you yeah i'm just doing it but
no those i see all kind of stuff like
that yeah all kind of like gimmicky
things you know the churro tacos
yeah the [ __ ] out of here bro well
anything you throw
throw hot cheetos on anything or like
corn or just like but here's my with the
hot cheetos
the guadalajara taco we crunch the
flamin hot cheetos on
top yeah you get that soft and that
crunch yeah
and then we send one of those tacos you
ever seen that big fat mexican girl who
does everything with
flaming hot cheetos yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah she eats
yeah cheats yeah and she's just thick
and eats that taco and she's like
tonight
venice 9 pm damn my lips are getting
chopper
yeah we gotta try some of these tacos
what have we got in here today
well we got i bought tacos for everybody
oh gang man um
we'll start any girl business partner
too man
you serve it and the other one explain
what uh is being served
yeah absolutely yeah
have that where'd your boys come in from
san pedro oh
damn texas right here it's like uh
oh yeah i've been over there before 110
until the end
that's for shops taco right there oh
yeah that's what shop's talking
big boy that's too heavy for you daddy
that's uh it's got coleslaw
yeah that's uh right there that's that
that uh
crawfish boil one what's this the salsa
uh that's for
uh your uh taco but this one's just for
uh
damn these are this is my style yeah
no that's not it that's chins yeah
that's something else it's it's
chin's not here right now you're right
we'll start we'll just start with uh
we'll just start with his taco okay okay
we'll move on so this is
for the food truck business i should
only take one bite i can't believe no go
ahead no i don't want to die your boy
i know i didn't want to ruin it you know
yeah i appreciate it you've been working
real hard
cheat on my son's b-day man i know i
heard i heard
uh so i couldn't find any crawfish it's
really hard to get over here oh yeah
it's hard to get
so i looked online for some crawfish and
they were like oh [ __ ] there's
three pounds uh three bucks a pound you
know i get to the
to the ending and uh turns out it's like
80 bucks
it's all shipping yeah so they shipped
that live shrimp so i got that crenshaw
shrimp right there dang bro
la river oh that's that crunch all
shrimp shot shrimp
that gun shot and then that comes back
yeah yeah
so that uh has shrimp onion potato uh
corn
um has a nice louisiana seasoning on
there and then a coleslaw
with the comeback sauce on there and uh
yeah it's gonna be a little spicy
nice and salty you know yeah yeah
you [ __ ] with it yeah thank you
tortillas
here boys oh he's got to tell me because
i i never been to louisiana so i never
really had kato is good man i think i'm
gonna get one more little bite
yeah you tell me another bite you don't
want no salsa on that [ __ ]
deal why are you like a hoe you knit
like a white girl man
but you talking about you're like white
dude
you can tell she's feeling on about how
spicy she makes that salsa that day
yeah that's that's how you set the mood
it's awesome
spicy she can't phase me you guys should
say
good man i think it's fantastic
i think it needs a little bit more of a
kick to it kind of okay
but it's a safe salsa dog this is
definitely a safe like a real good
safe starter for a uh it's got enough
kick for that start you know i'm gonna
be home theo i want to see it
i mean i think take me with you honestly
give me a tour you can go ahead
and get over some pouriers bro i never
been there so it's kind of hard to base
a louisiana taco when you've never been
there you know
no it's a good effort though yeah it
could go for some broken windows or
something
i use that crystal that cristal hot
sauce is what i mean yeah
it's good it even has a little bit of
that vietnamese style too which uh
that that tortilla is [ __ ] great too
yeah yeah we make them thank you
tortillas a lot of them you can't
[ __ ] the tortillas man
there's a lot of vietnamese tortilla
really man there's a lot of vietnamese
in uh
in louisiana okay for sure a lot of
people do are you guys big fans of the
double tortilla
i don't know about you taco no like when
they put two tortillas
yeah they're trying to fill you up yeah
skimp on the meme yeah that's what
they're doing
so what is y'all's home life like do
y'all got families or what is it
yeah oh oh there we go that's what's up
tj miller's hot sauce
hot sauce yeah tj miller has a hot sauce
bro everyone's making hot i'll put that
[ __ ] on my mind
yeah for sure i like spicy [ __ ] bro
yeah i'm ready to try the next one bro
that [ __ ] was fantastic yeah definitely
with that shrimp man at the end it has
that
real louisiana vibe i like that one i
think that's the
only fans only cat only talks oh only
for
only fan cats and only tacos so no
no oh yeah yeah and what's in this bad
boy uh that one's
gonna have uh lemongrass beef as the
base
and uh gonna also have a nook
chomp i said it wrong i mean hot sauce
daddy that nook chomp
yeah that's a it's like a that's a
dressing that they use in vietnam
uh lime and fish sauce wow and then
you're gonna have pickled carrot onion
and uh
cucumber on there with uh some thai
basil uh
then viet's about that life yeah they'll
drown bro they don't give a [ __ ]
and uh it's a little lighter compared to
the uh chin's taco
lighter in flavor i like carrots in my
[ __ ] i don't know why mexicans want to
put carrots and everything
pickled carrots my girl does all the
time what the [ __ ] you doing
this is a great dish so good [ __ ]
tossed carrots in there it's usually on
the side when i get it
it's for the texture i think yeah
usually when you get a real fatty meat
yeah you get a fatty meat i need crunch
on that minute yeah
and mexicans are more stabbing and not
guns right guns is more black
uh they went more guns now yeah i feel
like now there's a lot more yeah that's
interesting yeah i forgot mine i forgot
to bring mine right now
what's the best chain taco cheese jam
yeah like a duck great question shell
taco taco bell
chipotle no they're not tacos
let's see if i had to pick one yeah
i had a pick man that's a hard question
that's hardly suck
a little spice i don't want that i mean
i mean i always go taco bell when i'm
out feeling good about myself
del taco i don't know del taco i can't i
just can't do telltale our ballet driver
eats uh
taco and just takes dumps in here man
it just walks away and just leaves it
stanking or what no
he uh he assaults that bathroom on it
but he literally
he goes to the bathroom probably i would
not joke seven times someday he's i was
yeah
he's on the hour dog at least he shows
up to his [ __ ]
he's just you need to get his
this is good this is a little bit more
it's it has a different type of spice
kind of but it's more like a springtime
taco
yeah that that that that's what i
noticed when i was uh doing a lot of
research for the
uh the via taco and the korean taco
it seems like a lot of the korean stuff
is more for like
trunk food you know it's like a lot
heavier those vietnamese and they they
love
like light you know light like summer
flavors yeah i feel like it's really hot
over there
thank you wow two for two boys all right
let's go
damn bro all right oh man you know the
uh
a lot of things you don't know how they
got started i have no clue
like think about uh nascar do you know
how
sure don't the bible jesus
yep so some things you do the bible but
i'm talking about his mvmt watch company
two college dropouts brendan this part
now you can [ __ ] tune in to college
drop
i'm the only one with the degrees out of
it me with the semester at the
c degree i got my master's from
semester at the c asked my mom that's
what you told me
you don't have a degree and then you
said you walked through the campus of
arizona
that ain't a good degree theo you don't
have a degree the lady said you're
running a fever
that's what she said what i'm talking
about is mvmt
watches two college dropouts got
together and said hey we want to start a
watch company
that is fair priced watches that are
classy looking and bam they did it
they sure did and listen you don't like
to spend money i do
so you could get a watch that typically
might run
for 500 department store or you can get
it from mvmt
and you're talking about these watches
are a fraction of the price
yep they have to ship right to your door
for free daddy
for free oh damn okay fine then you know
what sometimes i get a dope watch and
then also
if i have to do work on the computer
sometimes that the
the light messes up my eyes so mvmt was
like yo how about you wear some blue
like glasses oh some blue blockers
yeah dog i love that man yes if you want
to elevate your look with style that
doesn't break the bank
then join the mvmt movement and get 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns so you choose it you don't like
it you send it back
by going to mv mvmt.com
kats again that's mvmt.com
kats you know you've been looking at
watches on their site
so support the podcast hold the trigger
save money get the discount look man you
know about this but today's
episode is brought to you by kratom man
yeah man i'm talking about kratom that
super speciosa kratom listen kratom's
the wild west you never know
oh i want to try it but is it legit is
it pure it is if you use superspeciosa
i don't do a single episode without
kratom i don't do any stand up without
kratom i swear by it
and maybe it can help you out but you
don't know where to start this is a
great place to start
so if you're gonna try kratom it has to
be from super specio all right
all you got to do is go to superleaf.com
kats that's super l e a f dot com slash
cats
can you help me out dude help you get
smarter would you like to be smarter
because i'd like you get smarter
all right then don't take a cradle dog
don't take super speed just
a specio listen all you gotta do is save
20 off by entering the promo code kats
that's getsuperleaf.com cats promo code
cats
so how do people get your tacos though
oh pop-ups
yeah so we're doing our first this is
your talk this is the bren shop hitter
yeah we're down we're dropping the
[ __ ] better be the best dropping the
first episode actually on
the second the second of uh march
oh okay so from there there's gonna be
one talk
and then at the end of march we should
do a pop-up gang bro
damn hey um that's
see how thick that taco is daddy that's
actually goat
this is goat that's go yeah so birya
you know you hear peter yeah right let's
go traditionally it's go so you it's
gonna taste like african bro
if you go to africa they have a lot of
that meat yeah goat meat for sure
south africa guadalajara actually there
are soccer teams that go
really yeah this is mascot
the goats i think they're the starting
uh the starting 11.
the baby goes they start from baby goats
i got shitty tv channels
i have like hbo max dude i'm not getting
that right now so so that's mulita style
yeah
it's got cheese layered on it on the bot
just
so i know we're talking [ __ ] about two
tortillas but this one's got cheese in
between yeah
and this is oaxaca cheese so that's 100
goat huh uh that meat yeah
and it's uh braised over for like i
braised it for about
overnight pretty much god it was nice oh
this tastes like it's been heavy petted
bro yeah yeah i took care of that that
was a happy goat man yeah i raised
myself that was a happy goat before you
slit his throat
i whispered in his ear fire boys thank
you yes man
i appreciate it yeah dude and la don't
have nothing like this wow
taco trucks kill it man yeah yeah around
here they kill it you're talking guys a
[ __ ] show based on food trucks that's
true yeah
yeah we're gonna get you a taco truck
man yeah man yeah
but if y'all had a truck work son it is
the hardest part is the good food
the truck we can find you can't just put
any taco in there
well that's the hardest part is finding
someone who makes good food well that's
the crazy part is that
um so anybody can get a recipe anywhere
anytime you know
tell them but i mean well yeah tell them
bro tell me where any time i'm
telling michael chandler
anybody anybody can cook anything you
want this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you want this beer
[Laughter]
dig in yeah hardest parts find something
to make a good taco yeah
authentic real it's weird that
anybody could cook and you copy a recipe
copy paste or whatever but
the outcome never comes out the same now
could you handle the pressure of being
in that kitchen and you know
um
high kicks with these bad boys it's ham
dude
yeah we got to find our way to get him
into a taco truck if they want to do it
100 percent yeah we don't want to
pressure
but also i'm pressuring you we'll have a
discussion about it let me get back to
you guys
yeah yeah here we go i'm in i'm
in man we'll definitely help like
advertise and do what we can and then
yeah man maybe we can have a different
conversation about it you know
um i'd love to commit to buying you a
taco truck right now but i don't know if
i can do that and i know you're not
asking for that but i'm just thinking in
my
head sometimes i get out of my out of my
ways i'm like yeah we're going to get
you a house
taco building do tacos
and there's a car wash outside hell yeah
you guys been around is there any tacos
at strip
clubs just the ever had a good taco at a
strip club no i've had good chicken
wings
i've had a nice prime rib one time we
saw that lady that fell off that pole
you want to put
pull that up nick this lady will
definitely you talking from uh a few
episodes ago
you know this is different person this
is somebody who had a real
we had that little thick mamacita
play the fake boy song oh yeah what was
that lady's name now here's a lady right
here dancing high in the background now
this lady broke her hip
it's all fun and games yeah she did she
broke her hip suit the company
she's like 25 feet up there she sued the
company
oh no see that one you're like oh that's
fun and then look
this lady's like oh we're all fun and
games check out my [ __ ]
and then boom baby jesus
broken hip still twerking damn
commitment still doing it
crying just [ __ ] just like
she's screwing her back her way back to
the back of the stage she's like
twerking her way to the back
no she popped up like it never happened
oh god she's trying to do head spins
everybody saw it she's all embarrassed
and the other one's acting like she's
hurt dude yeah yeah
that's insane man uh
yeah so maybe the stripping is out of it
it depends if you want to get messy you
know how uh lemon pepper drive rub got
started right
rick ross he was in the club with his
homies really and he was like man we
need good wings here he's like but wings
are so messy
and he's like we need a dry rub and they
came up with lemon pepper dry rub
for strip clubs i love lemon pepper
that's a great story tell it to your son
at night for years to bed
i only like wet wings man i like it wet
daddy yeah quits
looking at me dawg i told you before
they came in you decided to wear the pug
dog shirt
yeah but then he put the do-rag on you
keep looking at me dog with your eyes
bro
the onion's a napkin yeah looks like if
you're doing
[ __ ] mechanic work you're right yeah
but look how we do a mechanic work on a
[ __ ]
lunch house how's the oil on that taco
bro
oh
yeah you bet well look guys i appreciate
y'all bringing this in man we got to
have you guys come back
in uh at some point when we got the
whole crew here when everybody could
test out the talks
yeah and should we have them join in on
some uh
topics yeah you guys yeah jump on this
topic with us man
and uh let's see what we got here yeah
let's talk at this about the
future of tiny tacos king of this thing
yeah yeah yo what's up fellas um
got the uh got the bike in the back for
the thick boys club
uh but quick king understing it for you
uh being
28 years old and moving into a nursing
home
um got some money saved out my
grandmother lives in a nursing home
the amenities are really nice uh so i'm
thinking about
uh taking the plunge let me know what
you guys think
living in a nursing home is someone in
his 20s
gang gang orangutang well here's the
thing about when all your [ __ ]
roommates are 99
listen you can get real close with sally
she passes away
yeah think about that so you're
constantly dealing with
death all the time i think i hear the
same stories
all the time you know what i'm saying
theo
huh a nice bedtime story it's fun every
night though
every night becky every night bro i
i think first of all you'd have no fomo
anymore
because everybody's if you step to 7 15
you're the freaking
pit bull of this whole entire
environment dude like you're the
you're the rick james if you stay up to
7 30 you're rick jameson's place
yes bro you are a legend people like
what happened last night
you know all right so if you want to be
the coolest guy at the old folks home
do that bubba but also think about this
think about low-key
the life insurance policies you're going
to get in on okay you show up to court
dude and the
kids are like who in the [ __ ] is that
and you're like i'm your grandfather's
bridge partner
i'm your grandfather's best friend
[ __ ] i've known him for two
weeks and he left everything to me
that's who i
am hands down bro sometimes showing up
at the finish line is where you got to
show
up and then also dude you're going to
get
there's a lot of scx that goes on at
these places there is some wrinkly sex
and so you're going to get opportunities
and you're going to get
yeah is there sex in nursing homes what
does it say next 40
it happens a lot about 40 uh of people
between that age but yeah i've seen this
i'm looking for the studies that show
it's
it's rampant yeah if you're in the nick
dated an old uber driver yeah
i was an uber driver she was old well
either way
nick sorry nick molesta senior passenger
yeah
i mean i again if you want to be the
[ __ ] you know
the baller of the old folks home and
[ __ ] the old ladies
fire away my man i don't think there's a
lot of competition i'm not talking about
taking advantage of him bernie i'm
talking about enjoying somebody's
company
and giving somebody a little bit of love
in their life before they go to heaven
dude
and also you get to do all the games
dude board games arts and crafts bingo
stuff i love jell-o have you had jello
recently yeah i have sugar-free jell-o
i dude about two months ago i ordered so
much jello to my house dude
and i've been loving it it's great oh
you've got so great
now i'm kind of sold on it unlimited
graham crackers
vanilla wafers dude imagine just showing
up you roll out of bed at 4 45 a.m
that's the tough part you got to get up
early yeah get up early but there's no
sleep in there
you roll out of bed there's a hearing
downstairs because your buddy
uh gertrude died right yeah so you go
down there
his kids show up you roll off 20 percent
richer after an inheritance fair point
into a lunch that has ice cream
yes checkers all out you want to wipe
your ass
whatever you want those rails while you
[ __ ] yeah or while you're taking a bath
just wipe you off you're kind of living
like a king unlimited rails bro
even if you're just reading you have a
rail yeah now you can't bring any hoes
back to the old folks home so you gotta
you're gonna have to pay your dues you
don't think you can no
you can have visitors no you can't bring
some young thot up in that [ __ ]
maybe not during coffee times but you
definitely can man common assisted
living amenities
linen service sign me up unlimited linen
you know how expensive that is
medication management
give me all the pills i want uh in the
latino community do they have
do a lot of uh grandparents go into
senior care or no no
i've never heard of them no like
family's just family
you know to the end they still there
yeah
but it's kind of nice though right yeah
yeah it's pretty nice yeah you get to
spend their last moments with them it's
a beautiful thing
that's the problem with american culture
is we just ship off our seniors
they ship them off into like just uh
well because white people
our parents get on our nerves they kick
them out as soon as you're 16 you're all
[ __ ] see a peter and debbie
yeah there's no sense of like uh yeah it
gets a little bit like you want your own
space yeah and rightfully so
yeah maybe but um what else you got nick
i say king it man i'm for it and i think
stuff like this is going to start to
happen more i think you're going to see
people want to have a more
community style of living here's the
problem though you bet you better keep
it
high and tight man because you bring
coping in that [ __ ] everybody dying you
know what i'm saying so you got to wear
a mask at all times if you're going out
playing with
basketball with your buddies you come
back we gotta get jacob tested
cause one covet positive and that old
folks home everybody dying like [ __ ]
dominoes
yeah there goes your whole crew there
goes your best friend actually decided
to grab
tacos at tiny tacos especially if
they're [ __ ]
yeah they're breathing on each other i
don't know if they're sexually
transmitted cove it is there
not but they breathe in children no you
can have sex with a mask on
yeah um okay i'll king it if he wants to
do it i'll king it okay
a lot of positives now that we talked
through it yeah dude imagine right now
you roll out of here you go back there
there's people downstairs always to play
with to hang out with always to read
always someone to drop knowledge on you
talked about jim crow laws
yeah talk to you about the wars yeah
civil war charlie chaplin oh yeah
charles manson jfk the notebook watching
the notebook over and over again
and everybody claiming it's their story
yeah should be dope man
i told you you said no i'm into it now
though yeah
what's up brandon it's owen here in
bangor north wales uk
gang god bless you welcome
do you want them would you have them
when you're gone do you want someone
parking their ass on your dead name
this one's for phyllis dole phyllis dole
rest in peace phyllis
what's up ceo what's up it's dole rest
in peace phyllis
so uh yeah let me know king ought to
sting it it was in memoriam seats
gangang i love this guy what's his name
all right what's up sia what's up
brandon it's owen here i'm back with
owen oh who's well's jack as well so
isn't he
uh jack shore yeah he's just sure as
well darren tales from liverpool yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and darren tell them what this [ __ ]
smoke boy me about [ __ ]
what 190 is that fair dude i'll meet him
at 100 dog i'll chop both my arms and
legs off dog
get something beat him in a dark alley
give me that batting and wheelchair
hell yeah bro i'll bite his [ __ ] anus
open hell yeah
no homo bruh yeah but nah man they're
both legends
um but yeah in memoriam seats
do you want that when you're gone some
big fat seat where people sit
or some wheelchair ramp nah build a
statue man
do something cool let me look man love
you
but also nobody no it's no statue
oh now we can do something like that for
you guys right here
okay look yeah we gotta be carrying
tacos
i don't need it big oh okay just dip
that [ __ ] in gold we'll call it even
we could do something small yeah yeah
all right we could do something that
would be honestly
you're thinking of the big like michael
jackson no come on now
i know where i'm at okay i think if we
do something that could be on a key ring
or something
yeah but you smash producer okay
so yeah we could do something like that
man name a street after me
yeah you could do that but if you live
out in the country you can do that
yourself
no i don't want some [ __ ] street
like rename abbott kenny rename main
street
i'll take it mlk street whatever you
want to do but they're not gonna do that
man i mean they might but they're not
you never know
i know you could take a whole freeway
yeah
the beach shop thick way yeah you go
down that 101 are you talking about
shops out
y'all took shop south man the traffic's
crazy yeah traffic fit
the traffic is crazy there's just taco
trucks everywhere
it's just ten lanes of crosstalk it
doesn't get you anywhere
it's just this you're going to circle
it's like a nascar track
yeah you're going these cte services
i respect that man oh here's the
stereotype right here dude
he dyed his hair he does this kind of
stuff man
what's up brandon what's up theo brayden
here from
blairsville georgia and i just got done
hitting that leg day at the gym you know
get my squad on
prove it and i got a king of this thing
it for you
the sauna it's about 180 in here
i love sitting in here after every
workout but y'all let me know what y'all
think
sauna king of the stinger gang gang
gloves
drip drip young man gang gang man i tell
you he loves the son as mr joe rogan
yeah
yo he swears by it and i was in the
sauna with him and we had a sauna off
and he decided to get as hot as he could
it was a mental thing he didn't have to
tell me
he was just like he said 180 i was like
this ain't bad 220
225 camel goes by dude i started
my skin got red i started i had to get
out of there yeah there's a mirage yeah
it gets weird in there
dude and they try to heat [ __ ] you where
you get so hot somebody tries to [ __ ]
yeah that's why i was worried it's gonna
happen and people are like i'm not
[ __ ] you that's your imagination
well my ass really hurts yeah he uh when
we got out you could tell he won you
know
yeah he's like too hot for him like yeah
way to go dude you stood in the sauna
longer than me way to go yeah he's
like 7 000 shades of red yeah way to go
doug
yeah dude i mean he that guy joe rogan
is a damn meat snowman dude i mean
he is just he can handle that heat
extreme he's going full throttle
he's going off he swears that's why he
doesn't have covet and [ __ ] really
vitamin d
sauna i guess dude fouchy ain't saying
that
yeah but foucher could get these hands
dog yeah what does the latino community
think of fouchy man you guys believe in
the virus or no
you guys getting the vaccination i've
known people that died from the virus so
i i kind of believe in it i'm a belieber
okay i mean it's real for sure 100
yeah thank god you're smart do you think
we need like all the precautions that we
have you think it's overkill
i mean it it's tough because it's all a
basis thing it's not it's too many
blankets you know i mean it's like uh
certain places need certain things and
you just can't just put everything under
one thing
oh yeah yeah i mean i mean
dude it's tough but you'd be singing a
different tune if you had that taco
truck and they shut you down
yeah for sure you got a restaurant and
they shut you down i feel
like hold on people can't come here but
they can go to ralph's the big business
that's what i'm saying like but the
small man's out
you're me seeing your different deaths
i'm saying these blanket statements they
can't be
putting right you know what i mean they
can't like uh
how do i say yeah yeah for sure [ __ ]
that well it's crazy too i think
uh it's also it's weird like you can
build another restaurant
outside of your restaurant and then you
can have it
insane and then after you build it and
after you waste all your money on it
then they're like i never mind
let's close it again or how about if i
go to check in for the restaurant i have
to wear a mask and as soon as i sit down
a foot away i can take the mask off and
they have fans blowing yeah isn't that
great that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah it just doesn't check out man
i mean it's just i just don't i i think
it's just a lot of overkill especially
well especially now
and so you can't let the lord literally
man sometimes you got to let the lord
work the lord's sending something now
not
some people's it's time to go to heaven
dude it's your time man
yeah now if you don't believe in heaven
he is [ __ ]
yeah okay but that's on you that's on
you
man yeah you could have went every
sunday like everybody else you're still
thinking about it that's on
you brother you go to church every
sunday
i don't go every sunday night okay but i
believe in heaven i've already committed
to the fact that at least when i die and
they're like hey do you believe i'm like
you boys go to church uh no
to but after i grew a certain age i was
just like i can't do this yeah
yeah put me to sleep especially catholic
church too long
put your ass to kneeling up and down up
and down dude i went to last baptist dog
and we got the wildest [ __ ] over there
dude it gets funktified up in there we
had the breath
at our church one time dub rat yeah what
was she doing
doing the music man i don't like mittens
anymore
[Music]
yeah they get hyphy in those trenches it
gets wild
to heaven when you're in a black church
oh yeah you get the most feeling i think
i feel like i could shake this gayness
going to black church
feeling per minute shake it off i don't
like men's
feeling per minute you get in black
church you get the most feelings per
minute
yeah but what about uh in the latino
church what is what is the vibe in there
like
boring just listening to a guy talking
for one hour oh
that's it worse than the podcast and
they have a lot of uh
the worst podcast ever
podcast in general is it um do they have
a lot of molestation or something
in that church or is that more just yeah
i mean yeah i think that's just
everywhere i almost became an older boy
i was like
they're pushing me there
you got that perfect body type for altar
like tiny get on here
tell us about that new taco of the month
yeah i know
i'm good no i'm good i i rejected the
hell out of it damn
dog don't lie dogs
saw this gorgata here goes a guy right
here and this guy's obviously
i think this guy's in prison good
lighting
that nose is lit up theo brendan
cat nick chappelle and the rest of the
crew because you never know the [ __ ]
you've got there these days
nathan here coming from the uk started
to lose my hair at 29
just wondering what you guys think when
you start to lose your hair should you
comb it over
shave it off or talk to hims about some
hair loss treatment let me know
yeah doug here's the thing what you
don't want to do is try
to hang on to it then you got that
shitty nest up there
what you got to do is do like lewis
hamilton did jeremy piven
lebron james donald trump man you get
that here p
son you know what i'm talking about the
hair piece or you get
implants either or i i think
is the hair piece coming back like oh
yeah because because you look at lewis
hamilton the before and after is
nut toes now he has a gillion dollars
but
look at piven you know piven was losing
his hair so much he played [ __ ]
uh on seinfeld uh what's the guy's name
george
he was george costanza's double because
their hair was the same
what that's tough go to lewis hamilton
though
he's the tough lewis hamilton straight
was going bald like jeremy pippen
has cornrows now okay so there's his
hair
has an afro now what's up that could be
you guys
that's dope we're all doing pretty we're
all doing all right you're right you've
had
seven hair procedures i've had one or
two i don't remember if i've had two i
think i might have you said you enjoy
surgery
i do mine's getting thin is it no you're
fine it's just once you take some off
your back and put on the top of your
head
i i i might that that's what it'll lead
to yeah use that thing like a woolly
willy where they just drag something
from your beard up to the top
yeah and speaking of hair i need your
blessing on something deal yeah what you
got that
rat tail yeah let's see it bro
well i don't know what what do you guys
think of it just
want your opinion oh [ __ ] apocalypto up
in this
park oh yeah that's an apocalypto here
man dude i think you could go yeah
probably even one more inch off the back
just go one more inch lower yeah yeah
yeah i wouldn't take any more off the
top daddy but
yeah i think you do another inch down
going more you're good are you losing
your hair
is that was that is that the like isn't
it you're losing yeah let's not take any
more off the top
you think i don't know man he looks like
he has good hair no you have good hairs
is that for you know the four hands
look man i think uh it depends some
people looks good with bald haired
if bro joe rogan looks good with bald
hair you know uh
some dana white rogan jeff bezos has
more money than god
he looks like [ __ ] bezos it's his eye
he has one eye bigger than the other
what i've never ever thought looked at
the guy at all and been like oh this guy
looks five percent decent
oh dude nick bring him up look at him
now
mr steal your [ __ ] money trt
here rocked up but now here's one of the
things about trt once you get on to
once you go bald then you can start
doing trt because you don't care about
losing your hair anymore
correct that's one of the tough parts
about testosterone replacement like if
you get on it while you still have hair
you're going to lose the hair maybe
yeah so
where are we laying a lot of beanies on
this one i'm saying
if you got to do it you got to do it
just don't try and keep what you have
and you look like homer simpson shave
that [ __ ] off or get the lewis hamilton
yeah look i think it's about i think i
would love to see somebody bring back
the um hairpiece that's what i'm saying
and it hasn't been attempted in a long
time a lot of white girls a lot of black
girls wigs man
a nice wig cost you a couple grand but
that shit's fire
but a man wig has got to be coming soon
we could not be too far from somebody
saying i'm going man
it's a lot of maintenance is there a lot
of wigs you guys see a lot of wigs
i just see a lot of like those toupees
that they just glue on your head
they're so good that sounds like just a
pain in the ass yeah
so good you just don't notice them
anymore they got that good oh you know
another
great hair story is brian urlacher the
the chicago linebacker legend
he was bald his entire career got on tv
somehow grew here
kevin costner has
hair machine gun kelly was going super
bald
look at come on dude look at that now
now he owns part of the company restore
here and she and i was a youth pastor
i mean um
crazy though right yeah yeah it is crazy
man that kid don't
there's hope out there man yeah there's
hope out there
there's hair i mean in the future they
also said you there's a company now you
can take some of your hair
mail it to oh wow that's spray paint if
you don't want the pittsburgh steeler
helmet for two
[ __ ] hairpieces yeah that was cool
but here's the thing man
a lot of i feel like a lot of black and
latinos guys with darker skin can go
bald
headed yeah this is way better yeah it's
just like a white guy whose ball just
looks like an
[ __ ] yeah it's just spooky kinda
it's just a great it's aggressive a bald
white guy like oh he can't be fun
i don't know but some guys it's it i
guess it depends on
but yeah i think if you have if you have
more skin color and you go bald is kind
of better
rogan's the only i get only guy i know
who's bald who's fun
name one other guy who's semi-funny with
the ball dead
funny just cool to hang out with most of
them are dicks
super rich though this guy ron i know
professor x is pretty cool
joe the plumber we had on this past
weekend yup he's bald headed
oh my pops he's bow he's there is he fun
yeah he's
yeah he's watching he's a good time he
has a good time yeah yeah yeah and does
he drink does he smoke what does his
uh he used to he's a he got a sober now
so
he's still fun he kept that that energy
from being all hyphy and stuff and he
kept it and
you know your boys tequila fans yeah
yeah yeah all right what you got here
nick and here's a young guy right here
wearing carhartt
shout out john chris man this stuff is
unbelievable another big
another beanie same brand too what's up
brendan what's up d.o
huge fans out here in south carolina
hauling that fuel
anyway got a bait club for you you want
that trashy ihop
or you want that smothered and covered
waffle house showing up
drunk at 3am what you think
gang gang show up buzz buzz amen brother
first of all
hauling fuel is not something you want
to tell your mom you're doing
no and also focus on the road my man
this is all about the camera like
[ __ ] full of gasoline back there
this is the most dangerous ever king of
the stage yeah just driving through this
forest fire with
70 000 gallons of fuel and he's on his
[ __ ] phone
yeah is that a seat belt yeah
just eating a match sandwich right here
at the old fuel plant
um what's uh did what was this guy's
question about burn victims
waffles or ihop let me think walt house
or ihop man
i like waffle house is exciting
walt house is gonna have your head on a
swivel all times yes a fight might break
out
somebody else takes your waffle yeah we
go to one at the
in baton rouge or christmas eve i think
even we walk in
it seems like everybody's just kind of
chilling like six tables in there a lady
comes over asks
if we want something to drink we order
she comes over again
and so we start to order food and she's
like
can't you see our [ __ ] chef quit chef
tiffany quit i have no idea how you guys
are on this place
well why don't you tell us that first of
all when we came in
you let us order drinks now we're
[ __ ] sitting here drinking we can't
even get
food yet we're stuck and then she asked
me to
she said if anybody wants to go outside
and talk to chef tiffany
so i rolled out there and slipped her 20
bucks dude chris get her back in there
yeah got her back in here oh hell yeah
tight move money time save christmas
drive baby it was cool man we had a nice
little time but definitely you're not
going to get that
at uh ihop right pay way more too
right it's expensive oh yeah there's
yeah
it is and there's too many levels
there's more management and
micromanagement
at walford house it's you it's one lady
who
maybe is working maybe is not working
and then the chef is right there
there's six feet of sex that's what i'm
separation you know like
the seats are like right next to the
grill you can do i mean yeah you can
yeah you they have like the bar that you
consider right you just reach over
whenever you want
whatever you want you gotta ask nobody
and ihop has unlimited pancakes too
right
i think for a while they're doing
unlimited paintings
i don't like that they're not good
pancakes no it's
gonna eat like what it's [ __ ] food
three i know it's getting stronger
you know what i'm saying but bang for
your buck waffle house man for sure
hands down waffle entertainment value
yeah i saw it i saw
pam slap his house dude you might be
yeah exactly you go viral on world star
fight breaks out there's chicken waffles
world star you boys go viral you toss
the taco in there
product placement bro it's like an
audition yeah yeah
dude yeah i love that yeah there's a
burning wall file so you sneak in there
and get a freaking taco on the grill
man runs into burning wallpaper
what else you got nick that's it damn is
that an hour yeah
[ __ ] daddy yeah beautiful fast
feliz man you got the one last taco if
you guys want to just kill it which one
is it that uh chin's taco
uh we haven't tried that yet not chins
oh [ __ ] let's do it all right
full gamut ot someone's getting paid ot
and then i feel bad there's a lot of
tacos here nick you gotta try some oh
yeah oh nick dude they're so [ __ ]
good i'm excited
here i'll just have one of these make
sure you have to open up the other thing
it is yeah bulgogi uh more carrots huh
and what is bulgogi it's italian
i'll be right back because i'm about to
boogogy this girl
well that's what got your friend in
trouble is it you're right
do you have it right
if it's 0.5 i'm taking the over yeah
okay for sure because you guys tried a
lot of different
foods from a lot of different places
that diaria you looking for napkins
i want you guys your mouth full can we
do a shameless plug right quick
after going yeah man yeah do work man
follow us on tiny's tacos on instagram
youtube channel dropping march 2nd first
episode check us out
dog you guys trying to make tacos for me
and ben askren on food truck diaries we
want to we're talking truck though she
can pop
up that's okay you guys could pop up
yeah be fun do it out of your van
ben ask grant then ask him and there's
fights this weekend too fight night
yep yeah yeah yeah i was hanging a block
of witch oh can't wait
and counting down peter peter
yawn al joe jermaine wow
amanda nunes megan anderson that's not a
bad one to bet on nick
millions of beasts i'm betting on laura
sanko dude
what are you betting on this [ __ ] hot
yeah
well she's a minus ten thousand dude
gets my money i've got eleven two
thousand dollars i've been betting on
him every week
dude i'm gonna dress up like a cattle
and just show up on her property dude
just to get her to touch my back
[Laughter]
like man this one doesn't want to milk
[Laughter]
yeah she's very knowledgeable yeah yeah
she's a legend man
she's a legend i would fight her even
for charity oh that's [ __ ] up
i would beat her i would beat you up for
her
right now goes hey can you beat up like
i'm so sorry i have to do this
asked me to do this too oh robin hood
over here
you're going to step in and beat up a
woman yeah you
you got to wear that pug shirt though
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying that hard scarf
club baby taco is fantastic too
white belt nation man yeah bee shop
one's my favorite though
of course and not just his name after me
but it is spicy
actually theos was right there one a one
b i can't pick a fave
i don't even know i mean it's it's all
just good to me i i i i
i just feel good yeah i was hoping to
have chin and cat be just again
they passed away
they put them on a bench you know yeah
yeah yeah that's true
that's a good call we didn't even answer
that guy
no i said i want a statue remember oh
yeah you want a statue dude i'll take a
nice bench man
um r.i.p billy conforto dude i'll say
that
one of the top homosexual prize fighters
of the late 90s early 2000s
and we got to get a bench for him out in
louisiana but um
yeah i would get a bench what what's
another thing you could get
a bus stop a street bus bus stop yes
but then people's always doing drugs and
[ __ ] fist fighting
that's whatever daddy that's true you
slap your advertisements or wash
yeah car wash
a taco truck probably ooh memorial taco
truck that'd be good oh that'd be good
memorial socks soccer memorial
socks is kind of yeah that's it people
don't care that what yeah
[Laughter]
tacos were fantastic though yeah let's
figure out the business plan
food truck popping up this year's in
uh march 4th oh perfect beautiful march
4th so the following week i'm in
cleveland march
11th through 13th cleveland ohio the
week after i'm
spoken get you some dog
for sure yeah and i'm not really torn
anywhere but um
you're doing sponsoring l.a yeah doing
spots around la and uh
that's it just happy to be here man
shout out tiny tacos man thank you
fellas
thank you thank you guys stay tiny this
is awesome
now let me broadcast about this little
podcast king cause he got rasting cause
he fought back
theo got that hit
hot dog just kidding didn't send that
pic
that would be too premature just like
nick i'm slick i'm sick
too legit to quit they be calling me
chappelle cause i got the trick
and tell me how am i supposed to live
without chin singing he
[Music]
i think you'd be surprised one second
years ago they tried to okay years ago
they tried to tell me you don't got the
stripes webby now they call me conor
mcgregor cause i got a tiger belly i'm
prophetic my kaveli duggan like to black
call me dalia cause my pocket's heavy
cheeto cause my rock is ready when it's
time to rock call the bird to get his
chopper ready now though browse palm
sweaty probably vomit mom's spaghetti in
this state of mind always try to keep it
balanced so i'm younger than delia but
my soul is old as calling
yo brandon looking like he live with 16
don't matter god bless me like i got bad
allergies this boy might just burn white
rabbits like
dick boy bike club burn those calories
[Music]
here we go
you